I think it's a big tragedy big tragedy
for the country in for the world
for 300 years the Romanovs ruled Russia
as czars loved feared revered respected
but all too often those who fly highest
fall furthest World War one brought
Russia to revolution in 1917 tsar
nicholas ii was overthrown Lenin's
Bolsheviks seized control and for 78
days Nicholas his wife Alexandra and
their five children
Alexei Olga Tatiana Maria and Anastasia
were imprisoned here in what used to be
nikolai patias house now the church on
the blood in Yekaterinburg on July 17
1918 the royal family members and their
staff were woken and told they were
being transferred they were scored down
here to what used to be the basement of
the party of house the firing squad
entered and twenty minutes later the
three hundred year reign of the Romanov
dynasty was over Russia had died and
that moment when he was killed
Russia died two years later after the
fall of communism the church was built
to commemorate them as holy martyrs but
after the crime the Bolsheviks did
everything possible to erase the
Romanovs from history after the
execution the Romanov family was brought
here to God in a Yama and dumped in this
old iron mine the Bolsheviks poured acid
over the bodies and burned them
continuously for two days and three
nights trying to get rid of every last
remnant of the Czar's power the fishtail
McSteamy machine most of us you store
but you get to Odessa but I do blogger
regime there is no simple way to look at
the rule of the Romanovs and many here
feel that what followed was even worse
but
from the ashes of Russia's past comes
the promise of Russia's future
[Music]